I actually I gotta get something
straight about Dave I actually like the
guy he doesn't like me I know but he's
he's entertaining it went ago parties to
me he entertains me when I see him I go
look at this guy now look at him look
what he's doing it's entertainment you
know first of all when I hear the new
album Eddie would have benefited because
you guys can still write songs you can
still sing a top level at your age
you've still got the voice these could
have all been van Halen songs in one way
or the right I haven't spoke to him for
100 years but to any guy savanna since
the 2004 the tour ended week I walked
offstage and went that way Eddie went
that way Mike went that way
al followed Eddie it sense and the crazy
thing is even on the Sam and Dave tour
Sammy said to Dave a day let's go out
and sing a song together how fun would
that be you couldn't do it he wouldn't
allow himself to do it I don't get it
does anyone get it Mike no our guys were
pounding on his dressing room door
backstage gone come on Dave come on Dave
nothing Dave nothing why do you think
because I have no I think you're a
better singer and maybe it was like not
he didn't want to be on stage with you
and be shown up I'm saying with better
singers than me many times and it's like
yeah it's good it's it's not about being
better like I said Dave could he could
go out there and entertain the audience
a little bit better than I can
I mean if he wanted to steal the show if
we were standing he could have stole the
show and you wouldn't mind I would have
sang he could have danced you know would
have been a great whatever you have such
a great [ __ ] attitude danced around
while you think but what a wonderful
moment it would have been to say all of
this for the band's absolutely don't you
think - there's the idea that and this
still blows my mind that Sammy Hagar
came into that existing band and the
odds are a billion to one that it will
work Dave was a big presence in that
band there's no question 5150 comes out
and now you got to go on tour and you
got all these fans were David Lee Roth
habla hey how do you power through that
where do you find the [ __ ]
inspiration oh we walked out on stage in
to barricade the first show we did we
were I was nervous I said well they're
gonna think cuz we were only played
5150 record and we played jump when I
brought somebody else up to sing and we
played one way to rock my song and the
rest was just 5150 and jam so we walked
out on stage the barricade came down
before we played a note and that we'd
look to each other what let's go and it
was like that from then on now
look what a guy leaves a band like David
those fans didn't they didn't come see
us anymore but I had a huge fan base of
my own and it they came together they
got along it was good it was fun I got
to tell you that was the greatest time
and in my musical career